engineer ABD gaur Khan for saying his to
Z thank you so
much most
welcome Chan guest
dear brothers and
sisters it is an honor for
me this
opportunity on the
subject which is so great the miracle of
the Holy
Quran for which I am grateful to the
Muslim Community and the sh in
particular and the visiting guest you
you really honored us to be with
us thank
you the topic is so huge that 20 minutes
25 minutes is just just just make
some
introduction and and maybe if some time
is given I think there is a topic
this one works for which I have worked
for 18 years you I can we have to speak
on that for one or 2 3 hours so that
will
clear in proper way what Quran says but
anyway because of the time I have to
keep myself within the time so what
we do I just start from one
verse and then I will go
further
okay okay
so this verse is related
to you know the Christian delegation
came to the prophet peace be upon him
to Medina from the ground for the
interf dialogue the de so these verses
there were some verses which was
released from God Allah subhana tala and
he addressing the prophet to
tell one of good verses it is the
chapter 3 Al Iman the family of Iman
verse4 so it
says said he said asking Prophet Allah
God say say we have believe in
Allah and what was revealed to us and
what was revealed to Abraham Isaac Jacob
and The Descendants and what was given
to Moses and Jesus peace be upon him and
to the prophets from their lord we make
no distinction among any of them and we
are Muslims submitting to them this
this point is very very important we
make no distinction and how I explaining
it you know the why we make no
distinction
we we have been ordered by the our
creator make no distinction why because
all the Divine
religions have the same message and that
message is that is two components that
message has two components one is to
believe in one God and to worship him
alone this is one part the other part is
to do natur
Justice by
maintaining the God created balance on
so now our problem
is what is justice natureal
justice and what is the
balance now these two things not moving
the N Justice and not knowing the
meaning of the balance in Arabic words
it is means
not knowing these two things the
humankind is
nowadays
hugely in a spiritual crisis because
they do not know what is the meaning of
natural Justice and what is the meaning
of balance which is mentioned in
Quran
so the answer to this two
question is given
by verse 39 chapter 51 of the Holy
Quran and this is the
verse upon which I spent 17 18
years through the study of physics
science what is this so this
verse
say and of everything we have created P
so that you may have
instructions this took me 17 18 years
and I could only understand started
understanding to the advances in physics
the advances in physics so this is a
very important verse and it is a medic
itself so let me you know how proceeded
you what we should know now you know
divide this verse in two parts one
is and we have created pairs of
everything this is one part you take the
other
part there are instructions for us Allah
says he does not do things that you
know he has created this creation in
the in P there was lessons for us so
what I did we you know the people now
you know very limited translations are
available but my 18 years of research
through the Sciences their discoveries
speak this you know what I did you
know
everything what is
this so I started working a
so my I can briefly tell you I you know
everything from the thing I had to look
for something to to explain it to to to
thean so I choose one English word which
is
existence existence now I an existence
but this table is also existence is also
in existence if America is an existence
small other count also in existence if
the universe this Hess is existence so
the small partic things at are
existences so what is you
know and for example PE so PE you not it
but it is the name of some
existence so anything which has some
name it is their existence so Allah subh
said that all these
existences are
impairs so
this the when there's no you will be
surprised to know
that am coming to this material part
but then we come to the social part you
know
this atom this just time is very short
so I will just give brief
examples atom which is
10us 10 of CM across in language if CM
that 2 and 1 half CM 1 in 2
cm if you split it up into pieces and it
is still 10 billion part
10 billion Parts 10us 10 10 billion
parts so that is the size of the atom CM
10 billion
parts and there
is nucleus of this it and that is
10us 15 of a CM across that means the
nucleus the nucleus is about
100,000 trillion time the ctim
that that's but you
know this nucleus has two this
nucleus and this nucleus has two
particles which is proton and neutron
and they becoming a make the the the
atom neutral but the which what are
coming you know to the the surprising
for us that
scientists discovered that electron or
proton are not the
only partic so they they discovered one
other particle which is below this level
and that was B and scientist said no
there must be another qu because physic
believe that everything in the universe
is in Fair so scientist one and they
found the counterpart so they call it up
for and down for then another time came
there somebody the researchers they go
on and they found another discrete
particle lower in range besid so they
they put charm C so scientist said this
is the in the book you know John griin
this one of writer science writer John
Gan and you know there are so many so
they say the scientist say look look for
another for the counterpart there is
must be a counterpart because
the is so they found another part and
they gave another
name went down and they even in a
smaller range they found another
particle and that particle this again
said that you know look for the the
second the counterpart and
there Parts you know so three after that
there is another scientist his name is
hi so hi partic he said hey S no what
okay we name it it does not exist name
it now the land the
laboratory which the government there
very governments they spend 10 billion
doar to to to make that large harder
this is a li
Inland so they they what they are
looking for the HS and in 2009 when they
made the initial experience to
indication came they Tak in p and now
they will be making another experiment
to confirm this so you know just to
to to
this is just American what I telling you
then another
scientist well
known chairman of Cambridge you know
chairman he said there he found another
thing antim anti particles so the matter
itself they are in pairs then antimatter
the antim again the same anti anti they
are there so that now you know there are
other
dualities Mass wave Duality the
scientist said I think I should not go
further because become too much scient
STI but I come to the social part you
know
the so there is nothing even believe
even empty space you know nothing so it
is the name of some existence empty
space because we call it empty space
even this is the creation of a
spare that is rual particles and anti
particles it is said by this famous
scientist anyway nowadays this the
chairman so these are you know
everything in F see you know
very professor of quantum engineering
mechanical engineering in m University
he writes B programming of the universe
everything this digital technology yes
or no yes or not get so let me finish
here because it is so huge what is you
know that what what the what are the
less come
to so this
everything in
p this is the
balance this is the
balance the scientist and the physicist
call super symmetrical Universe
soon in brief and this is the balance
inan I am going ahead when there is a
m so it is this balance so you know the
question was what is balance and what is
natural justice so balance I explain in
some way through what is natural Justice
through natural Justice is related to
his
balance to maintain the balance of our
universe to maintain the balance of our
universe this is natural
Justice if you if you cut 10 trees you
have to plant them trees because God has
created a balanced Universe with the
scientist have discovered
now but so us I come to the the lessons
what are the lessons lesson here is you
know you cannot for example you know let
me say what is the meaning of fa because
to to make more clear you know any two
thing this is not just male and female
of any two things become air
when there is a common
purpose which neither one of the nor the
other member of the
fair can achieve it
alone both have to
complement then and then there balance
complementation no another thing I
so the birth of his child simple example
neither
man woman
that you have to complement so this the
entire universe there
are as many pairs in this universe
according to physicist and my study of
18 years as there are number of
functions and in other words there are
as many pairs as many for any
existence to come into being existence I
told you anything so for any existence
to come into
being there must be a corresponding P
for the child for peace for
anything there must be a corresponding
pair so that means that and and why
there must be corresponding pair because
the birth of a child is a function so
for all function there must
be so this is you know this is the
balance this is the meaning of the PIR
so now we come to what are
the what we what do we get so it is
clear that it s americ when the
scientists believe non-muslim scientist
that but there
are I will pick up some only three
lessons because this this I have written
three books on this 18
years research it is one terrorists
are born when the P Break when
unbalancing is created there are ter
work so the United Nation and
president was very kind to appreciate
this and there is a peaceful world how
can we create peaceful world Quan says
how this and this is the miracle you
know this this I will explain later so
this this is here so I will speak about
three
lessons which which is Will better par
occasion lesson number one is that you
know God has created a difference
between himself and what he has
created because he alone can do anything
singlehandedly
he do
and done so this is his property none
among what he has created none among
none among all existences which he has
created has this
power and capability so this is one
thing what does this mean this mean that
there is only one
God because he can do everything
singlehandedly and this creation which
the physicists have found there is no
possibility for existence to do
something singlehandedly unless it's
compliment some there are always
corresponding pairs for functions so
this is one
lesson lesson number two is that by
creating everything in
place God has created a balanced natural
system we call it the univers natur
system whatever it is
which is
a complete source of meeting our all
human
needs irrespective of any discrimination
this is male this is female this is
Muslim non-muslim black white to the
human being but he has created he has
created this balance Universe which is a
complete system of our basic human needs
and which is our basic human needs that
means it is the complete provision of
our human rights this is another
lesson so the third lesson which I have
not I have prepared some summary for you
I will distribute it but the thir lesson
is that with
this this this Miraculous
Creation the entire universe ining we
this
everything this function as one
integrated
body so that what does that mean that
means if I D
someone if I kill someone or i d someone
so I am injuring the bigger body and
when I am injuring the bigger body it
head me back so I get inured I I I
should have effect so environment what
is what this is just e example I will I
will not give more example because they
will become political but come to the
scientific example
that we destroyed by deforestation by
smokes this this we
destroy this Bal body HS of f now these
strong
and and this and it is again given in
the Holy Quran that men will do things
with the with it own hand which will
create they I
mean disturbance in know water
and on the sea and is what we are we are
looking for so this so these three
lessons keep in mind the less the number
of lessons is very few but I good D
know to to because the the beginning was
that all religions
are the same message so let me there are
two verses in the Holy Quran which is
testifying you know the first verse and
that is one verse is
in
Allah this says that
I send down the book which is the Quran
in our case and then Misan and Misan is
this balance i i a detail of this mean
is the mother of all balances
so want to maintain this balance so
he warning anding us the blessing and in
he the
English translation is I have sent
down the book in Tru and the Mis is this
balance and look the day of judgment is
coming mean the day of judgment is
coming what Allah is doing he's telling
us to maintain this balance this bigger
balance which I spoke about you have to
maintain this balance to those who
maintain this balance but why he has
mentioned Quran because how to maintain
this balance the instruction in Quran is
to
main so this is why he mentioned Quan
and is coming the is coming
so those who will maintain this balance
they will be rewarded the on the day of
judgment the hour is speak and those who
will Disturb This bance they will be
punished if not forgiven by him this is
one ver the second ver Allah says that I
sent Messengers
all Messengers I sent Messengers with
scriptures and the
balance again there is mean and
scripture the holy
books so that people make justice so
what we derive the Quran himself said
that why this
balance I have created this God created
very but the holy books
you the instruction how to maintain this
B so the all the D books they have the
same message to maintain to create
Justice natural Justice to do natural
Justice by maintaining this balance so
now I go straight to some Miracles
because the time
is you know the the the I hope
prepared some list for you but I will
start from you know the einin theory of
relativity general relativity this is a
very huge subject and understand but
that is in the Holy Quran D you just for
example he said this this turn the
fourth dimension and the three dimension
univers so this is space and time so
space time Einstein says that SP space
time rule on itself and it will go to
that compa position and then it will
reop the universe will reopen so the E
they call it cylic Universe because it
is because they say no there is no God
because everything is created by
yourself and they take this example
in their favor that you know it is
created and and cre universe but says
Allah says 1400 years back in verse
number
104 that it is me who is
cre Allah subhana tala glorified and
sign work 1400 years back that look I
rolling back the universe this is in
Quran I'm rolling back the space time
and in a way you are rolling back the
books the paper for the books and I will
recreate when rolling back what does
that mean that it will come to that
compa position and then he say I will
reopen recreate I will repeat I will
repeat the creation of this universe and
then he says it is my promise I have to
do it and this is what Einstein has
discovered around in 20th century the
vers is revealed in 7
Century now another this are my recent
work science of
space science of space you the Holy
Quran now believe it there are many
verses that only physics after the
discovery one can go to the near
meaning so the science of this this
record this I will be
Distributing make cop on my website will
be available for you through this rocket
you know how I came to know to translate
in this way because there are there are
seven verses in the Holy Quran seven
verses 33 to 39 but I missed the 31 also
because when Allah
starts this amican this for us so he
says all prominent beings he's
addressing men and J oh prominent beings
I'm going to attend to you and then he
says so you will read it but he says
look
you if you want to go out of the domain
of Earth in the space do good do good
they give permiss but you cannot do do
it without some pushing power some
Authority from me some knowledge so this
is one thing and then he says that he he
mention he give hands about this teolog
will send down the
flame of smoke and
fire and then you will not defend
yourself that means that this will be
the te mean not defend yourself I he's
giving us the type of energy so this